show the clip that this is some of what
Mike Pence was saying today this day
should be an inspiration to every
American because thanks to your
leadership from early on throughout this
process mr. president you've put the
health of America first mr. president
you have forged a seamless partnership
but it's all a result of you tasking us
with bringing together and together as
you've said many times together we'll
get through this so anyway this week's
ass-kisser of the month goes to Mike
Pence here are some of the other things
he said that weren't in this speech he
said president Trump is in such amazing
shape scientists now believe Kentucky
Fried Chicken is good for you he said
President Trump could make women orgasm
just by liking their tweets his body
creates no waste who Trump's once-a-year
excretion produces a perfect Cadbury egg
sometimes when Jared and Ivanka are
having sex they both pretend the other
is dumped this amazing Katy Perry's baby
is and they wrote it the CDC is testing
his semen as a vaccine for corona virus
this nickname for the rock is Little
Miss tits he's an incredibly
generous lover both because of his
concern for her pleasure and because he
always leaves a tip
you